hi there here i am back in vancouver
uh i don't have my selfie stick so i
have my phone propped up against my
computer here
um my 90 day challenge in korean is over
in fact i realized it ended that a
couple of days ago
so
what i want to do today is tell you what
i what i achieved and what i'm going to
do here on in
so what did i achieve now let me see if
it's possible
to see this ah you can't see it okay so
i'm gonna read you my achievements last
three months as it shows up on my
maybe you can see it i don't know anyway
it says here known words total i
increased my known words total by twelve
thousand words
uh and i took it up to forty seven
thousand
uh i created nine thousand six hundred
and three links that is to say i saved
nine thousand six hundred and three
words in words and phrases
now
of those
2 379
i learned so
i went in there and when i saw them i
said i know this word and i no longer
had it underlined or or in yellow and
converted it to a white word i do that i
did that call it 2400 times
but of the 9600 9600 words that i saved
i actually know more than that what the
number is i don't know
maybe half so i'm not far off
you know i say i i now know 47 000 words
in korean i probably know roughly 50
000. bear in mind that in korean there's
a lot more
situations where the same word has
different forms or two or three words
that you already know are put together
and and so they're counted as a as a new
word in fact it probably didn't learn
that many new words it says here that i
listened to 26 hours that's not true i
listened far more than 26 hours but i
didn't record it in the system
and i read 114 000 almost 115 000 words
of korean essentially on link so that's
the activity that i put in
and and you know we measure activity at
link because
really i think in language learning if
you can commit to a level of activity
the rest will take care of itself you
have to find ways because the
content is interesting or because what
you're doing you enjoy doing it somehow
that you maintain a certain level of
activity if you do that you're going to
familiarize with yourself with the
language you're going to accumulate
vocabulary you're going to get better
and so far as my ability i mean i feel
that i speak better hannah tells me i
speak better she's surprised
every time we speak how much i have
improved just through listening and
reading
but i didn't really speak that much i
mean i don't know how many hours a few
hours of speaking um ultimately i should
get myself to a situation where i can
speak a lot and that then would activate
a lot of what i have learned
from a situation where i was struggling
to read korean even on link because the
dictionary definitions weren't helpful
often and because i couldn't make sense
of how they use words even when i had
the words now when i read like as long
as i can look up the words that i don't
know or i'm reminded of words that i
have previously looked up i can
comfortably read through these difficult
political podcasts so that's the plus i
enjoy it
it's that's a big plus
on the downside i still find it
difficult to understand these podcasts
when i listen to them however i've
decided that i've put so much work into
this for the last three months it's time
for a rest i'm gonna give the korean
some benign neglect now i have talked
before about
benign neglect and language learning i
find that when i leave a language for a
while then when i come back to it i've
actually improved
not initially but within a day or two
i'm ahead of where i was
that there seems to be a gestation
period where all the work that you've
put in and it's kind of in the brain
somewhere and it's sort of
you know baking
and that when i come back to it i'm
better so i'm not at all concerned about
leaving my career and instead now i'm
going to go at something i've wanted to
do and that is my slavic languages i
want to get better in russian
which is the best of my slavic languages
i want to work some more on polish on
czech and on ukrainian and
the principles of the grammar in those
languages is so very similar that to
some extent i'm reinforcing where
there's a problem is because there are
so often almost similar sounding words
that sometimes have different meaning
and so then you get confused as to
whether a word is ukrainian check polish
or russian but i'm prepared to deal with
that because i'm going to enjoy it
you know it's just right now i can grab
the russian book off the shelf as
chekhov some of his stories i can enjoy
reading some of that i'm doing a polish
book
in link because there there's more words
that i don't know
i want to get back to my check i want to
get to a point where i can really say
that i speak those four slavic languages
well
so and that means i'm also going to
speak more i've got a uh
i'm going to speak on wednesday with one
of our tutors here i think
and so that's my plan for the next
little while but it won't be sort of a
challenge i'm not under any obligation
to do anything but i'm
to the extent that i do language
learning activities i'm going to be
indulging in my slavic thing and
enjoying that so
uh there you have it that's the final uh
video on the korean challenge and uh
we will have more challenges i know
there's just talking with the people at
the office they've got something planned
for starting the new year and
you know i'll just take a few more
minutes here
i was uh went to lunch today in a
japanese restaurant that's run by
koreans i often go there just to chat
with them in korean and lo and behold
sitting beside me were these two ladies
speaking japanese
so i after a while i can't resist you
know so after a while i asked them if
the japanese food was good or something
and so then we had a conversation with
them it turns out that one of them is
chinese so i spoke both korea japanese
and chinese and of course they were
delighted and a bit surprised that i
spoke their languages
and of course then i s then they were
talking about where the which esl school
they should go to to improve their
english and of course not surprisingly i
told them that they needn't bother going
to a school they should just study at
link i gave them each a card
and of course gave them my
prep speech
and told them that
you know your attitude is important and
of course the time you spend with the
language is important then the attitude
includes the sense of you got to try to
enjoy it
and so then the lady said well yeah but
what if you don't enjoy it what can you
do
and i said well you have to try to find
even something that you're interested in
some activity that you enjoy and i said
besides that
you have to
initially force yourself push yourself
into it so that you you get a few
victories and that encourages you and
then pretty soon you start to like it i
always say as they say in french
the appetite comes with the eating and
so the advantage of a 90-day challenge
sometimes if you've been holding back
and you feel you haven't been making
much progress in a language if you say
okay come hell or high water for the
next three months i'm gonna commit to
this certain level of activity i'm gonna
read so many words i'm gonna save so
many links i'm gonna listen to so many
hours that that very often will push you
over the hump you'll create some new
habits you'll realize that that the
effort is rewarded with some progress
and then you're on your way and you'll
get that positive attitude that you know
you can do it you want to do it you like
doing it which is so important in line
with learning there you have it and
happy
challenges in your language learning